this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] Merry Christmas it's
Thursday the 22nd of December the joint
is brought to you by DraftKings listen
DraftKings gonna make sure you have a
green [__] Christmas in more
ways than one DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
NBA NFL UFC it don't matter Maryland
sports fans listen up DraftKings sports
book is now live in your state Baltimore
do your thing we're going to make some
[__] cash this weekend with the
football Saturday the ex [__]
Extravaganza not to mention basketball
is [__] making it it's tremendous
right now this is the heat of NBA
basketball season and right now new
customers bet five dollars on a pre-game
money line on any NBA team to win their
game and get 150 and free bets when they
do plus you combine multiple bets for a
bigger payout with DraftKings same game
parlays this weekend I'm looking at a
lot of action Philly against New York
Christmas Day Milwaukee against Boston
you got college basketball you got
college football with Georgia playing
Ohio State oh my God I love [__]
George in this game but listen if you
want to get into the action you got to
download the app right now go to
draftkingsportsbook app download that
[__] and let's get this holiday
hoop action going sign up with code Joey
j-o-e-y plays a five dollar pregame
money line bet on any NBA team to win
and get 150 in free bets if they do only
at DraftKings Sportsbook with Coach Joey
middle and age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details The Party Starts Today download
the DraftKings what book app and let's
make some [__] geez the joint
is also brought to you by rocket listen
most Americans think they spend around
80 a month on subscriptions when the
actual cost is closer to 200 you could
be wasting hundreds of dollars each
month a subscription you didn't even
know about that's why I love rocket
money formerly known as true bill the
app shows all subscriptions in one place
and cancels whatever ones you don't want
rocket money could even find
subscriptions you didn't know you were
paying for this is the app you need for
2023 right now you want to start saving
money things are going to get rough
rocket money will help you put a little
money in your pocket you may even find
out that you've been being double
charged to cancel a subscription just
press just press cancel and Rocket money
takes care of the rest it's that easy
get rid of useless subscriptions with
rocket money now go to rocketmoney.com
slash Joey again that's
rocketmoney.com
r-o-c-k-e-t muddy m-o-n-e-y one word.com
slash Joey It's Gonna Save You hundreds
of dollars per year things are rough
right now I'm trying to help you guys
out cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com
code Joey let's get this body started
it's Thursday the hours are coming I'm
ready to sling some dick
foreign
[Music]
what up you bad [__] it's
Thursday the 23rd and I know before you
say something Joey where the [__] is the
year gun it's it's like
that's it we were talking about this
[__] in October how fast it [__] went
two [__] days look it's Thursday
tomorrow is Friday you're gonna be
running around those last you know
stressing yourself out and then Saturday
it's going to be [__] freezing
freezing this week I love it nobody's
doing dick on Saturday there's like four
football games where the weather's gonna
be under 10 degrees
10 degrees Kansas City there's a but
this is a freeze over the next two weeks
so dress warm [__] uh that's it
man
that's it we [__] did another goddamn
year how many Christmases we [__] do
on this podcast now 13 14 [__]
Christmases
it's uh it was a great [__] year I
got to tell you something this was one
of my best years
in a long time and if you
know you whatever I don't know how
people judge their years uh you know or
judge that time everybody's different
you know when I was young there was uh
another month I didn't get arrested you
know like you [__] another month I
[__] did Co you know you just move up
you know and
this year was really uh I was looking
forward to this year
for more reasons than when I was [__]
when this year started uh January I was
still a little [__] off kilta
I was confused I didn't know what I
wanted to do you know and uh
I was struggling man I was struggling
mentally a lot and I'm not ashamed to
say that that's the problem with today's
world everybody's a shame
to talk about their shortcomings it just
wasn't
[__] clicking for me uh I had signed
up with better help I was talking to
Dana
every week then we cut it down and twice
a week I was doing uh
it was like I had a peel and artichoke
to figure out what my next [__] move
was you know I was telling Mike listen
man I knew
comedy my comedy career was changing
when I got the knee surgery when I came
home from the knee surgery and after the
knee healed up and stuff and I mean it's
it's been two years now but I got to be
as honest I can with you I'm not the
same I don't trust this [__] leg I
don't trust it I've already had a bunch
of little little things I can't imagine
what a little thing happening on the
road you step wrong you know when in our
business there's a lot of stages and
there's a lot of steps and there's a lot
of Darkness you know what I'm saying you
know when you're [__] getting on
stage they if you're in like a high
level Led Zeppelin band a Nirvana yeah
the six guys with flashlights showing
you where you're going I'm just a
[__] bum comedian there's nobody
there with a flashlight you know so I
was just concerned you know so ever
since I got the [__] knee thing
I was always uh after the pandemic I was
always like mentally shot when I got off
the plane here I was shot and then that
one year whatever I was withdrawing I
was shot I was damaged goods and then I
just made an effort to get better like
how am I going to get better I gotta you
know [__] work out I gotta be around
people then I got covered see I started
the New Year perfect because I had covid
and now that last of the fear had gone
away
you know we were some and listen some
people covered came for some people some
people jumped up and [__] down for
days for others
some people to fear and for me it was
just like they caught me early you know
I was uh vulnerable
I was [__] weak and they caught me
and this is what happens as long as you
know it but January was crucial for me
started the year just doing the podcast
with Mike the book was handled in
and uh I felt good about all that stuff
but it was still the question of what I
was going to do so I had to sit down and
start from [__] scratch
and then uh you know
I was thinking about doing comedy in the
summer like it's so weird how you for me
I always let life dictate my what I'm
doing like I was thinking about doing
comedy in the summer thinking about
thinking I got a call from Bert
uh well no I got a call from Tom
and he wanted me to stop by NJ Pack and
see him in Newark
and I went down over my friend Sean
coach and I [__] ended up going up on
stage and
it was uh exhilarating I mean it was
like getting it was like uh [__] you
know somebody putting horseradish in
your [__] your whole body is like
Wasabi you ever get wasabi and it just
[__] overwhelms you with a big piece
of Wasabi you didn't know how much you
put up there that's what it was like I
was overwhelmed so I didn't know
how the feelings I was getting were like
happiness
but it's like anything else I broke my
toe in Jiu Jitsu last week I didn't tell
you good yeah I got a broken [__] toe
and it's funny how I didn't even know it
was broken
so I came home and took a shower and
then afterward
I was like that night I was like man my
foot feels weird and like a day later uh
I took it off to put I was like what the
[__] going on with my foot and my toe
is black
I thought the fungus had gone into it
I'm like I'm dead
but I didn't feel it and then yeah
Friday night it hurt and then Saturday
went away but I sounded I put a little
Bengay I had my wife pull it out because
the toe it's Louis it's the second one
oh the big toe you have the big toe then
you have that Louie that one that
sometimes is bigger than the big toe
just by a little little [__] [__]
hair it's a little bigger so I had Louis
I broke Louie Louie was like this he was
bent
in my foot so my foot was out but Louie
was bent
like this so my wife had to pick Louie
up and then she pulled it out and then
she realized Louis was just [__]
dangling
so we put like Scotch tape around they
were like [__] like a little duct
tape not duct tape you know the training
tape I put a little the CBD lion tape I
[__] had to cut it and it's gone but
my point is I didn't know I broke it
until I got home because I was fired up
at Jiu Jitsu the adrenaline's gone so
you don't know until you come down at
this [__] problem there you know
so I didn't know how to gauge it and
then they caught me off balance you know
they called Bert to put me on a [__]
door and that blew my [__] mind then
Rogan called me and it was like
overwhelmed and next thing you know I'm
in front of 5 000 people Atlantic City
for the last two years I've been doing
140 people at Uncle Vinnie's and now I'm
in front of 5 000 [__] people
I was blown away but that weekend also
let me know I didn't want to be in the
hotel Saturday like that was [__]
brutal for me like that was just I was
not used to that at all my Saturdays are
free I'm outside watching kids playing
softball jumping up and down barbecuing
whatever now I'm inside for [__] June
4th
that was brutal so that was I had to
deal with that like
I don't know if I could be in a hotel
all [__] day Saturday and then I did
the bird tour and uh
I love bird took care of this bird's a
[__] star
it just didn't work for me I I it wasn't
who I was anymore I wasn't
I didn't feel like staying up till 3 30
in the morning talking to people like it
just wasn't you know for me I took the
residency this summer to make up for the
shows I canceled Uncle Vinnie's I want
to be a man of my word
I did the shows and uh
I booked the New York
shows to
lift me a little bit
you know sometimes
I don't do this often and I don't uh
want you guys to do it often I don't
recommend it
but every once in a while just to lift
uh just to light a fire under your ass
you gotta play big
you know it's like
my daughter plays and uh
you know eight to ten or some [__]
she could move to a different division
but we wanted to play with better people
around her
and she would be not as talented as the
other players so we played her for the
10 year old
so when she was nine she was really
playing a 10 year old lead with 10 year
olds bigger girls and she didn't do as
well but she learned the game a lot
better
sometimes you have to do that
to [__] uh see what you're about you
know
I was watching what's that movie with
Marky Warburg where he
takes over for it's like Judas Priest
the guy's gay rock star rock star is a
great movie Marky Wahlberg and Jennifer
Aston Aniston did a great job
but even a situation like that where
you're you're a cover singer in a band
Mr cover singer in a band
a band that does weddings you know
bar mitzvahs they do a bar from time to
time so maybe 250 is what they're used
to playing for
random one day you got a call [__]
you're the Chinese guy from Journey you
sound just like Stephen whatever his
name is Perry
right his name is Stephen Perry the
singer from Journey whatever and you get
the call you know now you're not
performing in front of 250 people no
more you're performing the [__] 20
000 people a [__] night you're not
ready you're not people like uh you're
not ready you're not ready but you are
ready
do you know what I'm saying you aren't
ready but you are ready you just don't
[__] know it and yeah you might eat a
bag of dicks the first night
who doesn't
even Marky wardberg ate a bag of dicks
in the movie remember he fell off the
stage and he caught his eye and [__]
like that he didn't know what the [__]
he was it's a different but when you get
there you'll adjust quickly like you'll
[__] adjust like I even know this for
me Hollis gave me the blue belt
I didn't feel like a blue belt I still
don't feel like a [__] Bluebell but
up my game I hadn't noticed some
improvements since I've gotten the belt
because now
I'm lifting you up you know when I was a
comic I would never try the headline it
was just not good for Uncle Joey the
headline I was a very good feature but
even when I was at my top of featuring
all those years for Rogan
I stayed away from that lining I just
stayed I I never felt ready for it and I
was okay with that there's some Comics
that they do two spots and I'm a
headliner okay you know find out for
yourself what the [__] you are I'm not a
[__] headliner after two spots
so I was a great feature but I didn't
like [__] headline
I didn't know it was a headliner guess
what I started calling clubs and they're
like we're booking you as a headline I'm
like
that's [__] 800 more if you're on the
basic plan and I would go
I don't want a [__] headline and they
go why not Joey you know the headline
okay
and I'd expect to never get hired again
and then after the weekend I talked to
the guy and he'd go Joey you did a great
job
considering what you were telling me on
the phone
you did a great [__] job you know you
may not feel like I had a liner but
you're playing above your head now and I
remember like
the headline you gotta have 45 minutes I
would have like 38.
so you got a stretch you got to sing a
song somewhere in the middle you gotta
tap dance you gotta hope somebody gets
drunk you gotta hope somebody pukes you
know I wasn't I still remember going to
Jacksonville Florida
in 1998 talk about not being ready
had gone to La I had I was at the store
I had met some [__] comics
and Jimmy Schubert was one of my great
friends we're still our great friends I
love Jimmy hopefully I'll see him next
week when he's in Philly
uh
Jimmy called me one night like on a
[__] Monday night and he's like hey
man I'm gonna I got a big problem I just
booked a movie
and
I got to work tomorrow and but I started
a week in Jacksonville for Creative
entertainment and I was like
he goes you want to cover the week he
goes I already talked to him
they said if you could do it you could
uh get on there he goes there's a red
eye tonight
or there's a 6 a.m tomorrow morning
that'll get you there and I was like
[__] it I'll book the [__] right uh
booked the morning when that was when
cheap tickets was big then there was a
company called cheap tickets
200 and under
I was there and a lot of you guys don't
remember this company it was the
original
they would guarantee you uh you know one
day two an hour flight on any flight
they would get you a flight for two
hundred dollars so
I [__] took the flight down to
Jacksonville Florida I've never been
there
I was just I expected just to go to like
Miami I thought Jacksonville was like
Miami and but I was excited to go to
Jacksonville because it's the home of
London skin it and all those
[__] up there so I'm like ah
I'm gonna walk down there and walk
around the streets
I get to the hotel the first night oh my
god when I went to headline that night
it was a [__] disaster
I went back to my room I cried a little
bit I went home my material I went back
Wednesday night and I bombed even harder
than Tuesday night and that was the
schedule
for the rest of the [__] week
I just kept bombing and bombing and
bombing I would get them for 25 minutes
I would get them for 20 minutes and then
bomb for 25 I would get them for 20. it
was just not good
I even went and talked to the manager
and asked them if they wanted me to
leave you know I was like do you want me
to leave the guy's like I'm having a
good time watching because he's just
bombing he goes I'm just dying dying of
watching you bomb and I'm like that's
not that [__] encouraging you know
but that weekend left me [__]
mummified like I went on the plane I
cried because I didn't I took the word
was going to get out Joey Diaz just
stunk it up in Jacksonville you know
like the word got out don't ever had
line them again no they called like two
weeks later creative entertainment where
I had done the week for at the time and
said do you have you got a great
reference do you want to do more work
for us I'm like sure
okay it was great okay
but my point is that that weekend
gave me more knowledge than
like I still remember it I'm talking to
you guys about 19 a weekend a week now
this is when comedy was comedy this one
comedy was Tuesday through Sunday
with three shows on Saturday
7 9 and midnight
they were not [__] around these days
and here I am bombing after one after
the other as the headline I was like
[__] that butt jumping up to that opened
up the door and then I became a
headliner in time I I
I thought that you became a headliner
overnight like you just walked into a
[__] box and you became a headliner
but that's not the case and then as I
progressed over the years like by 2004 I
started going to these uh you know I
started getting booked as I had liner
and then I had to fill the [__] Gap
but I never felt comfortable as a
headliner
till maybe
2011 2012 even my first week as a
headliner after the podcast I did
Columbus and I ate a bag of [__] that
week a lot of people won't talk to you
this way a lot of comedians are going no
I killed because I used it as uh it was
always learning it was always a journey
anything you do in this life is going to
be a [__] Journey but we always try
to speed it up whether you have a band
whether you're a comic whether you want
to be a fighter whether you want to be
whatever you want to do we always try to
[__] speed it up we we can't wait to
get there
for me it was something different
I had a feeling I could get there but I
wanted to take my [__] time because I
knew there's a really popular
uh
story on Instagram going around right
now it's Robert De Niro I don't know if
you guys have seen it it's like a black
and white little thing where it's just a
motivational [__]
and he's talking about when you get
there
he goes when you feel that you're at
that place where you want to be
relax
don't do anything
calm down and start thinking about your
next moves if you see this motivational
thing you'll die
but he hits it right on the [__] head
because that's what a lot of us don't do
once we start getting just a little bit
of success naturally we [__] want to
spread the word like we're getting you
know we want to get out there we start
getting cocky and that's everybody me
you that's all of us we all get [__]
cocky at times and we start finding
success and anything that we're doing
whether it's Car Sales you know when I
was selling 15 cars a month you don't
think I was a little [__] out of my
mind yeah
you know because this guy's selling
three cars and you're selling 15 like a
[__] Savage out there and they're
like what are you doing differently I'm
talking to people what
but it's always a journey like I was
always in a rush to be a [__] uh
we're on a rush to get rich
yeah we're always in a rush to get rich
but we're not it's a [__] Journey if
you're gonna get rich and you gotta
[__] plan or not I want to be rich
what do you mean you want to be rich I
want to have let's break this down
millions billions gazillions what do you
want to have you want to have [__]
Rockefeller money nah I just want to be
able to eat a cheeseburger at least you
know
at least you've narrowed it the [__]
down you know
so these are all the things I [__]
think about this time of the year like I
think about resolutions like what
I was starting to tell you guys the
other day like what things can I do
better in 2023 I like to improve the
podcast
I like to get it more uh you know give
you more options I like to
read more I want to lose 75 pounds
I want to and that dreads me because if
I lose 75 pounds if you think my head is
big now
wait till you see me then a guy like me
loses 75 pounds he's all head I'm like a
I'm like a [__] male that went [__]
for a female he could do everything he
can you get the titties you get the nuts
cut off you get your toenails done your
fingernails done but you still got that
big [__] man head you dumb
[__] your balance is gonna be
off you're gonna start falling around
like a [__] you know Weebles wobbles
and they don't fall down those
[__] so you know I'm looking
forward to losing weight but the size of
the [__] head you know I've dropped
like eight pounds on this diet already
it's not even a diet I'm just [__]
working out and doing uh Stupid Weight
Watchers which I love without Weight
Watchers I'd be [__] dead right now
but I want to read more I want to uh
write a little more
not comedy anything anything I've been
asleep yeah anything I don't want to
write comedy no more I just want to get
rid I want to get finished with this
book from A to Z I want to get finished
with the [__] audiobook
and I've I've written down like eight
ideas I have for uh for stories just to
put out like just stupid [__] that I've
always wanted to explore you know
somebody was telling me that they didn't
like the new Sylvester Stallone movie
the new Sylvester Stallone uh the show
have you seen it Tulsa came
yeah
I've seen three episodes
I think you gotta have Apple TV or
Paramount TV to have it you gotta buy
and I'm already we'll talk about
you know I'm already part of [__] 20
000 different packages you know right
you got Hulu you got [__] this one
you got that one everything you got to
buy a package for so I'm like I'll back
off with Paramount hey we still gotta
get Apple TV yeah so
it came on like three weeks ago [__]
it came on one night I was at the gym
and some guys were like
excuse me if you see the Sylvester stall
movie and I'm still vegetable on TV show
and all three of these guys are like ah
it was kind of disappointing we didn't
like it [__] He's entertaining though
but
you know we don't really like it okay
you know I didn't I don't care I'm not a
big you know
it came on one Sunday night it usually
comes on Paramount on Sunday nights late
like 11 30 or something
so it came on the first one came on I
watched it I'm a Sylvester Stallone fan
so it was entertaining I enjoyed it
but
no and I liked it like I'm like this is
okay you know then I watched the second
episode and
again it was okay it's not gonna win a
[__] Emmy or whatever like that but I
will tell you what I like about it
they took a chance
for the last 20 years I've been going uh
mob auditions
mob [__] uh TV show auditions mob
pitches you know people always calling
me hey man can you pitch this character
with me at the bit okay my pictures mob
TV shows it was endless I was surrounded
by that [__] in L.A
especially when I first got there
because The Sopranos have blown up like
in 99 2000 so as soon as I got there I
was struggling as an actor but then
soprano [__] started popping up and
thank God I look like one of the guys
and they took me in
so
the last 10 years have been going on
different pitches and I thought about
one specifically in 2013 right before I
shot Grudge Match
and this guy at a funeral Paula you know
this is about a funeral parlor and they
were a Mafia Family
and they had had this phenot ball for 30
years I don't remember all the
particulars
but in other words it was the same old
song and dance it's Gino
Nikki Louie meatballs
Tony hernia you know it was the same
[__] characters and I I remember when
he was reading the pitch if you've ever
been to a pitch meeting you know what
happens in a pitch meeting it's like
three people
produced to the writer and then one of
the actors and you go over what you want
for this I wasn't the lead the lead was
some [__] dude I never saw him before
never heard of him before anyway and
he's pitching and at the end of the
pitch that people said it sounds like a
great idea for a script it's not
something we're interested in and
then he goes you know I love he goes I
love this genre
but after The Sopranos this genre has
been beat up
Dave Dave
you know Dave you know and even the last
couple years the many Saints
Irishmen we don't know what it really
did because Netflix never gave you the
numbers
but people that I talk to don't like the
Irishman and I'm like I thought it was
okay again it was entertaining for me I
like dinero I like Joe Pesci I wanted to
watch Sebastian
but the problem was all these [__]
movies sounded the same
Angelo Johnny boy this that what I like
about Sylvester Stallone is he did
exactly what one of the writers Mr
Sopranos is on that I can't think of his
name right now
uh great guy great [__] writer
you got Taylor Sheridan on there the guy
that was the sheriff on Sons of Anarchy
he went out to become this big Hollywood
icon remember John burnt always talking
about him
and uh what they did was I don't know if
you watched this show
he gets out of jail
after 25 years I've always liked that
idea
the idea of you not being uh
in touch with the world and then coming
out and read this rediscovering
exploring the world
it's always been
a fascination of mine uh all that [__]
him going to New York and them telling
them listen it's 2023 when I'm you know
DraftKings is taking all our [__]
gambling action you know [__] and that
goes 50 of the vague the lottery takes
on numbers you know I can't compete with
two billion dollars uh they've locked up
the [__] uh you know the ports you
know it's not as Mobby as it used to be
you know the the the mafia has lost 60
of their [__] bread and butter you
know you still got loan sharking
and all that [__] but you know they're
few and far between
when they show you a mob movie now you
know you see these guys driving Mercedes
and she'll it's not the same
first of all if there's a mob family
they're probably down to 20 [__] guys
and if you think that they just deal
like for years when you watch all these
mobster movies we just deal with other
Italians whether it's not Italians left
they're all in jail or it's tough to
make a [__] dime here
so they're gonna have to they're gonna
have to be doing business with the
brothers with
the albanians with the [__] Russians
with the you know the Cubans for
bookmaking you have to to grow as a mob
family that's what you have to do today
they don't want to show you that in
these new movies that's why they're all
boring Sylvester Stallone show takes you
that like he gets to Oklahoma he gets
out of a cat boy as they go a weed store
Ryan he [__] shakes them down and
then he [__] who's the cab driver a
black dude
and he hires the dude to become his
driver
okay I could I liked every facet of it
except
the daughter hasn't talked to him in 20
years why has it always got to be the
daughter the missing daughter
they got to put it out there you know so
all that aside
I [__] love the show he's hanging out
with Gentiles he's doing business with
Brothers you know he's got a chick
that's in the FBI that he talks to
whatever the [__] she is that's a good
show for me it's tough to sell I like
that's why they used [__] Stallone
because anybody else like a medium range
actor is not going to sell that show
they're not going to jump on board
especially people from this area like
Italian always dealing he's doing
business with a Puerto Rican we're not
but that's if you know anything about
the mob today if you Wikipedia uh the
Genovese crime family I don't know one
of those crying families Luke Casey one
of those because I was reading this
about a year ago they were in jail
and in jail they teamed up with
the brothers whatever Black Gang there
is in there to sell cell phones
and then when the guy got out of jail
they were partnering up with the
brothers to sell cell phones why have
you not heard about that on a TV show
they don't talk about that [__] if
you're gonna make a show make it [__]
realistic that's all I ask but I enjoy
that [__] show for that reason
because it's not the same
you know well he's in love with Maria
you know his gubad you know it just
keeps going and going and you're like ah
we're all looking for a [__] change
so 2023 this is what you for some people
right now
for the last two weeks people been
thinking about Christmas and when
they're gonna get Grandma and you know
what they're gonna get their girlfriend
or who they're gonna get engaged to I've
been thinking about next year and I've
been pushing it on
patreon you know on anything I do I'm
like I'm really focused on 2023 and
unless you're [__] crazy
you know uh interest rates went down
right before [__] New Year's Eve so
you got to buy a house when uh before
Mike got here Trish was here who sold me
the house and I said to her your phone's
ringing she's like [__] Yeah it's been
ringing and she goes I just had surgery
so it's busy but I think next year is
going to be a little [__] rough for a
lot of people you're seeing the writing
on the wall this you know when you go
Christmas shopping this week I was
looking at I you know this is the [__] I
look at a lot of people are using their
cards man
you got to pay for that [__] well a lot
of people use them every year but I
think this year between the food and the
[__] my my neighbor told me the other
day she had a baking course to her
eleven hundred dollars this year
for the same [__] she spends 650 700
1100 to bake between the eggs this that
that [__] that
they're not running a [__] charity
out there at all they used to compare to
now for years I've been saying they're
not running a charity out there but now
looking back the last 10 years they have
been running a charity compared to
what's out there now
I want to read a little more I want to
be a
better Dad I want to be a better husband
you always got to put those down
because we always strive for you know
your house to be peaceful I got a great
house guys I I I'm not talking about the
house or the size or the bathroom I got
a great home uh it's peaceful there's no
yelling there's no drugs in this [__]
house
there's no alcohol
um
my wife is working again I mean it took
us two years just to really
get the law of the land the land of the
land of how to [__] make it happen
here but she's working my daughter's
doing [__] great
I could be doing a little better like I
wish you know listen I'm an action type
of guy like if you know anything about
me
I like jumping up and down but like I
was telling you before
I can't anymore
I wish I could I wish I could
you know I was thinking about Andy
Huggins he's uh somebody sent me a
message if I put him on the podcast Andy
Huggins is a great [__] guy I've
known Andy for many years in Houston
we're not tight
but whenever I was in Houston I had
conversations with them at the laptop or
at the last spot years ago
Andy Huggins is 72 years old
you've never heard of him he does cruise
ships
but he's 72 and he's my idol
because he's doing it how I would do it
he just shot a special
it's on sale it's on sale somewhere you
got to see this guy
and he gets up on stage once a week or
twice a week
when I heard about Andy like I just
heard recently about him but I knew I
always see he's on Instagram or Facebook
taking pictures from different comedy
clubs in Houston or one night is they
got a place called runyers rudyards that
was great it was like Monday night
Tuesday nights or something
that's the guy listen I I I've come to a
point in my life where I'm not going to
get on planes I'm telling you right now
I'm not getting on [__] planes I just
not the [__] mood for it I look to
see what the plane tickets were like in
February my wife keeps torturing me
about what are you gonna do for your
60th birthday I don't want to do
anything
I don't want to do anything I want to
get some chicken cutlets with some
mashed potatoes and some cream corn with
Jalapenos in it when the jalapenos a
slot oh my God that's good [__] that's
what I'm in the mood to do but uh
I looked at the plane tickets for Aspen
just one more hurray in Aspen you know
am I gonna ski I don't think so I'll get
my daughter in ski school yeah I'll tube
down one day you know February is a
great month because it's slow humidity
so the Sun comes on they do that bikini
skiing and it's just a great time of the
year to go and I want to celebrate my
60th birthday again I'm not cheap
but I'm not paying
it was guys they won fourteen dollars
to sit in the back of the plane
I'm not [__] cheap
but I'm not paying 1400 to get tortured
you know it's going to be late you know
we're going to sit on the [__] tarmac
for 15 minutes you know there's going to
be all this [__] so
it's like [__] you I'm not gonna pay
that money to celebrate myself I don't
even know what the [__] we're talking
about I got a yeah no no I do want to go
to [__] Aspen but I'm not paying that
type of money for my birthday I think
birthdays are [__] overrated anyway
after you're 21 go [__] yourself I don't
want to come to your stupid [__]
birthday party I'll go if it's a special
whatever but for me like first of all
guy I'm not the type of guy to throw
myself a birthday party
that would be a little [__] shitty
like I'm gonna throw myself to 60th me
with a scarf on like [__] thirsting
how the third and [__] I'm not doing
that [__] at all
and I really don't like [__] parties
like I really don't for me to be at a
birthday party is the most embarrassing
thing at the world for me for somebody
to walk up with a cake happy but when
I'm in a restaurant and somebody brings
a firecracker to somebody's table and
all the weight staff come up oh my God
damn that's not good I don't want that
to be me [__] you
yeah I don't want none of that [__] but
I'll tell you what guys
you know write your goals down what the
[__] do you want to happen I don't want
anything to happen in 2023 I want to
keep doing the podcast I think we're
going to go to the podcast once a week
we might start doing something with Vic
on Wednesdays so that'll be a little
better to add to this
Vickers in Ireland right now we talked
about it the other night uh just doing
the join them
Sunday the Monday motivation you know I
love Monday motivation even for me I
just like talking [__] just to get my
dick hard it reminds me not to be
[__] lazy
but uh
I'm gonna do that to the podcast on
Sunday so you guys have something on
Mondays I already know who want to do
uh a meeting that got Mike from El Nido
tonight I'm gonna meet Mikey from El
Nido and maybe get a
rent a space that's what I think we
really need I got to get out of this
[__] house you know
rent the space I'm gonna do uh something
for DraftKings on Thursday nights
where I uh
cover the week you know like uh Thursday
Night Football Prime Time football on
Thursday night
give you the lineups for Friday Saturday
Sunday just for myself just to [__]
around
over the last year I I love messing
around with [__] DraftKings I I
really do it's not gambling for me it's
fun because
gambling is when you put your life on
the line to [__] bet that like
there's a big difference between me
betting 200 on a Tuesday night that I
don't have I don't have that 200 but for
me to bet 200 on
something I don't have
for money that I think I need to you
know like I was gambling as a child as a
young man which I was a [__] child
immature I was gambling because I
thought I wasn't making money I thought
I was gonna actually make 30 000 a year
like it they're just running a charity
over there you can just put vets in and
they pay you on Thursday that's not the
way it works that's why I don't even
call it gamma no more it's just fun
should be fun
it shouldn't be like if you see a Sunday
game and some guys is holding his head
like a [__] statue that guy's not
having fun I don't want that at all
that's not why I work with the
DraftKings uh I I think it's fun for me
it's just fun you think you're
knowledgeable about something you know
how many nights I bet 10 bucks
10 bucks
DraftKings has these boxes at night so
like
tonight you gotta like maybe four or
five basketball games you can bet them
straight but then they have little boxes
like John Morant to score 40 points and
to have two steals another plan on the
team to have nine rebounds and them to
win by money line not even cover the
spread or anything like that
those things are [__] tremendous I'll
bet them [__] three three nights ten
bucks on let's say you I like uh
like last night [__] Milwaukee play
Brook I'm just throwing this out there
no no Golden State played in Brooklyn
last night
Golden State doesn't have their main guy
and [__] Brooklyn is you know hit or
miss the mix of one seven of that last
game so they look [__] good I think
they played last night but
you don't like both games like you like
I could see Brooklyn winning and I can
see [__] whatever winning so what are
you gonna do about 20 bucks on each one
and sit down no what you do is you just
go to those boxes and go I kind of like
them so I just bet that it's 10 bucks to
win like 91 some days
but if you take a beat and you don't
lose 91 dollars you just lose 10 [__]
bucks and then there's another box where
the star of that team will score 28.
Luca will get 15 rebounds uh a bird or
[__] on the [__] flag and then they
win and you put 10 bucks on that
and it's [__] fun for me just to
check the score maybe if the game is on
I'll watch it for three or four [__]
minutes it's it's it's nonsense I don't
word as gambling I worry this having fun
there's some nights I don't do [__] but
there's some days where last week the
UFC I don't I watched two fights I
watched the last two fights I didn't bet
it you know it's just fun I don't even
know what the [__] they're talking
entertainment that's all it is that's
what people get confused a lot of people
hit me up and go Joey I can't believe
you're promoting gambling No gambling is
if I give you the number to a bookmaker
who has a lone sharking [__] thing
and then you get in trouble with them
you can't get in trouble with DraftKings
or any of the other ones because it's
all uh credit card or [__] uh not
even ATM card
you have to have the money to do it or
PayPal like right now they're running a
special we deposit 50 bucks of PayPal
you you get a ten dollar bet for free
you know it's just [__] fun man
and that's it I'm looking forward to
2023. I don't know uh I'm gonna finish
up my two shows at the Sony Hall
and then
I got to do the audio book which you're
gonna take a lot of my [__] time guys
so I don't want to book anything around
that
and then uh March maybe beginning of
April I'm gonna have to start doing a
couple more podcasts and go down to
Austin see Joe Rogan I like to get there
you know in January maybe see Joe and do
a quick podcast just to stay alive the
book comes out on April 23rd
and then uh I don't know I was thinking
of maybe doing a monthly residency
switching it up
maybe doing one in New Jersey I've been
in New York for the last seven months
I haven't played in Jersey since the
beginning of September so I wanted to
give Jersey a breather
so I'll come over to the Red Bank Red
Bank has two great little theaters they
got the Count Basie the the big Theater
which seats 1500
and they have the little one on the side
so that's a thought I might have
and I'm just going to keep it simple be
a dad
I'm 60 I'll be 60 in less than a month
and a half why put myself over my head
if I want to do comedy that bad I'm in
the greatest [__] city in the world
so
that's it
I came to a conclusion I uh built this
up
nothing happens by chance guys I know a
lot of you guys think that
look there's a lot of luck involved but
nothing happens by chance
we all put hard work in and you know you
better fruits of it man little by little
it's a journey it's not going to happen
overnight if you're looking at 2023 to
be like you bust out yeah I agree with
you it's going to be a bust out here but
if it's not your bust out here remember
it's a journey it's not a [__] it's a
marathon it's not a Sprint you got this
and that's it man it's going to be a
great year I am so happy
and I put the work in this year you know
listen man I lost a bunch of money by
getting off the road what's that
expression you win the war but you lose
the battle you know I lost the war but I
won the battle
because I won that little you know I was
stressed out about money my my what am I
going to do this that it wasn't about
money
it's about you being happy and you being
able to be productive and you being able
to [__] do the things that you want
to do and for years I kept telling the
agents guys
this isn't working for me anymore
this isn't working for me anymore it's
not that comedy wasn't working it was
the way I was doing it that wasn't
working it was [__] backwards and it
was starting to bother me all that [__]
I had when I got off the plane I moved
here
was a ton of [__] confusion I was
just totally [__] confused and guess
what
I stuck to my guns you know as hard as
it was I got rid of my age in LA
I stay with the same agent I only went
with a different guy in New York and I
stuck to my guns I was scared there was
a lot of fear but guess what I did it
and now I know I could do this
for eternity I took a chance it took me
two years to get this down to figure out
a life
without having to go on the road only
when I wanted to on my [__] terms
and that's what I'm doing I'm living
life on my terms I took it down to my
terms always figure your life out and
stick to your [__] guns even if it's
making you lose money in a different
area who gives a [__]
you're going for you you're going for
your dream right listen I always enjoyed
doing it but enough I didn't want to get
on planes anymore I didn't want to deal
with these people no more I was sick and
tired of just doing things I didn't want
to do anymore but most importantly I was
sick and tired of selling my future
[__] rough to have plans and then to
realize you have something to do it
worked for the longest time
but it didn't work anymore so I'm happy
I made the adjustment
and uh
you got to work for everything you get
in this life you catch a break from time
to time you will but you're not going to
catch that break if you're not putting
the [__] time in so uh
I hope you guys have a great holiday uh
laughing gas has still got weed to help
you out remember we got Stoner Club
delivering in Jersey
and if you're in La just stop at the ice
cream shop I mean listen this laughing
gas is everywhere in California now
people really digging it we keep smoking
it
and that's it it's going to be a great
holiday I hope you guys uh
get everything you want for Christmas
but the most important gift you get is
clarity
the 2023 to do whatever the [__] you
want
next [__] I love you [__] uh
Mike and I were discussing that we don't
know what we're doing next week we'll be
back New Year's week
but we ain't working New Year's Day so
you might not get the podcast till
Tuesday that week so it'll be a slow
week the next couple weeks until we
figured things out
but have a great holiday with your
family and we love you I love you
stay black and we'll see you
[__] next week Tip Top Magoo
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsor Jack
all right you bad [__] I want
to thank you and wish you guys a Merry
Christmas again but remember rocket
money I [__] love rocket money you
think you spend about 80 a month maybe
90 on subscriptions but it's actual more
like 200. you could be wasting hundreds
of dollars each month on subscriptions
you didn't even know you had it that's
why I love rocket money formerly known
as true bill the app shows all your
subscriptions in one place and cancels
whatever ones you don't want rocket
money can even find subscriptions you
don't even know you were paying for the
cancer subscription just press cancel
and Rocket money takes care of the rest
it's that easy so do me a favor get rid
of useless subscriptions and save some
money with rocket money go to
rocketmoney.com Joey It's Gonna Save You
hundreds per year again that's
rocketmoney.com Joey cancel all your
unnecessary subscriptions right now so
you can save money in the upcoming year
rocketmoney.com
Joey the joint is also brought to you by
one of my favorites in all the world
DraftKings why it's fun it's easy
they're safe secure and reliable you win
they pay plus everyone can combine
multiple bets for bigger payouts with
DraftKings same game parlays and the
good news is Maryland sport fans listen
up DraftKings Sportsbook is now live in
your state so you can start betting the
Baltimore Ravens how's that
it's NBA season as At His Highest right
now new customers bet five dollars
pre-game money line and if any NBA team
wins you get 150 and free bets if they
do plus everyone can combine multiple
bets for bigger payout with DraftKings
same game parlays
download the app and get it on the
holiday action on Christmas day Philly
against New York Milwaukee at Boston you
got college basketball you got college
football and you got the casino so
download the app sign up with code Joey
and place five dollar pregame winning
line bet on any NBA team to win only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Joey
minimum age and eligibility restricted
Supply see show notes for details I want
to thank DraftKings I want to thank
rocket money
I want to thank better hope and I want
to thank you guys for being Savages and
always having my back I love your
[__] stay black have a great
holiday and I'll see you next weekend
Tip Top Magoo
[Music]